مخاوف عالميه غير مسبوقه منذ نحو 20 عاما
من احتمال انزلاق الاقتصاد العالمي في
دوامه ركود عميقه خلال العام المقبل صندوق
النقد الدولي حذر من امكانيه حدوث هذا
السيناريو ونبه الى ان الاسر والشركات في
مختلفه انحاء العالم ستواجهما وصفها برياح
اقتصاديه عاصفه بسبب تفاقم معدلات التضخم
واستمرار البنوك المركزيه في رفع اسعار
الفائده للحد من هذا التضخم فضلا عن ازمه
سلاسل التوريد وتداعيه سياسه ما يعرف بصفر
قافل التي تنتهي الوصين وقبل هذا وذاك
ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه والمواد الغذائيه
نتيجه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وتوقعت المؤسسه الماليه
تراجع معدل لنمو الاقتصاد العالميه خلال
العام المقبل الى اثنين وسبعه عشر في
المئه مقارنه مع 23% خلال العام الجاري
ويقول صندوق ان توقعاته للنمو في عام 2023
ستكون الاقل من نوعها منذ ان بدا في نشر
توقعات الاقتصاديه في عام 2001
كما لا يستبعد خبراء صندوق ان تكون افاق
الاقتصاد العالمي اكثر قتامه من التقديرات
الاساسيه فها هو كبير الاقتصاديين في
الصندوق بيير اوليفيا يحذر في تصريحات
لصحيفه
البريطانيه من ان هناك احتمال بتهاوي معدل
النمو العالمي الى اقل من واحد في المئه
في العام المقبل كما يتوقع صندوق ان ترتفع
اسعار المستهلكين الى مستوى قياسي في
الاقتصادات الصاعده والناميه لتصل الى 10%
تقريبا من خلال هذا العام على اساس سنوي
قبل ان تهبط بشكل خفيف الى نحو ثمانيه في
المئه في عام 2023
ورغم ان اجماليه الناتج العالمي تخطى
مستوى المئه ليون دولار لاول مره خلال
العام الجاري فان النمو مهدد بالتوقف
العام الجديد وفقا للتقرير السنوي لمركز
بحوث الاقتصاد والاعمال للاستشارات في
بريطانيا
كما يحذر صندوق النقد من تفاقم الديون
العالميه بعد ان تجاوزت 300,000,000 دولار
اي ما يعادل
350% من اجبالي الناتج العالمي لتبقى
المحصله المزيد من حالات التخلف عن سداد
القروض في البلدان الفقيره
وليست ازمه اسرلانكا ولبنان ببعدتين عن
الاثان على هذا الصيد
بيانات البنك الدولي تطهر ان الديون
الخارجيه للدول الناميه المنخفضه
والمتوسطه الدخل تجاوز التسعه التريليون
دولار في نهايه عام 2021 وهو ما يعادل
اكثر من ضعف قيمتها مسجله منذ وعشر سنوات